the reds are 6-0 and that starting
pitcher goes seven or more innings
pitched this season castillo looking for
a duplicate of april seventh as he takes
the bump
and he hits urias
well he got hit last night to start the
game and he gets hit today to open up
the game
swinging a miss out in front first k for
castillo today
rio to yelich and nothing close and a
walk for yelich and he's been getting a
lot of those here of late the brewers
have two on with one out here in the
opening inning and it's avi garcia
chance to put the brewers out in front
going after the first pitch and a base
hit into right field urea is rounding
third he will head for home and the
brewers get the early jump on castillo
and the reds here on this thursday
swing and a miss
fastball from castillo his second
strikeout
they don't look too comfortable
india swoops in from second
a pretty toss
luis castillo the lead off bruce comes
around shades of yesterday we know how
that turned out
round it out for the reds against freddy
peralta fast freddy pulling the string
with the changeup lately opponents
batting average 133
jonathan india chases the first pitch
sends one deep into right center field
avi garcia has it tracked and that is
out number one allowed out from india to
begin the bottom of the first
1-0 pitch to castiano's and takes a
curved ball and pops it up
jace peterson
for out number two
peralta with the 1-2 breaking ball swung
on and missed so peralta
issuing a walk to jesse winker gets a
pop-up and a strikeout and the brewers
have the lead after one
here's a ground ball to third suarez is
going to field it and throw in time to
first
swing at a miss
off-balance stroke from peralta third k
for castillo a one two three in it joey
vada will lead off for the reds he was
on the il for a period of time
and that ball is rocked deep right
center field
welcome back joey
home run number 301.
motto ties it up his first hit back from
the il is a solo homer to tie the game
in one you know we've seen some pretty
good work in the in the crowd in this
series now that that is laying out
that is
[Music]
that's incredible that's a big time
right there
and he's left-handed i like it kid
left-handers need more love in this
world
i smile too i may catch like that look
at him get ready he's going to be all
over every highlight show tonight
reds have made a lot of contact against
him
the pitch in there with a called third
strike on a slider that backed up
castillo
their strikeout number two for freddie
peralta
they all fits to india swung out and
missed breaking ball it's another
strikeout for peralta back-to-back
punch-outs here in the third
ground ball to peterson backhand stop
and a one two three inning for freddie
peralta good pitching match up unfolding
in cincinnati we are tied after three
garcia to right center castellanos on
the crisscross nine straight retired by
castillo here the bouncer past vato that
played in
the first in the fly ball earlier this
inning and there's one to left field the
zig and the zag by winker he adjusts on
the fly 10 in a row retired by castillo
hard ground ball up the middle nice
adjustment by farmer oh that was a hot
potato and he handled it coolly 11
straight retired as luis castillo has
rounded into form
and he rifles that one to right feet and
that was going to be my next comment his
ability to hit the ball to right field
allows him
to stay
with that pitch that slider down on the
way longer
fake one unable to check as he strikes
out here for the second time today
one away in the fourth
and that is strike three called
at the knees or close enough
without number two
pitch to barnhard and that is strike
three call got him with a fastball so a
double a walk and peralta gets three
strikeouts he has six through four it
remains a one-one game and now gibson's
called in for the tarp so they just came
out to start manicure work on the mound
but david bell joined the conversation
and they're going to tarp it up but this
is a pretty hard range so after a fairly
tight 37 minute delay luis castillo back
on the hill struck him out there's the
change up down and in and he picks up
right where he left off that's 12
straight retired by castillo
tip
strike three
that's five strikeouts for castillo
13 consecutive brewers retired
tap to third hard charge suarez bare
hand infield grass throw in time
bang bang at first 14 in a row retired
by castillo
peterson can't handle it
sliding flip not a time farmer arrives
jesse winker he has walked and grounded
a second so far this afternoon
opposite way through the whole base hit
wave is on they'll test yelich
and he concedes the run alive to second
farmer scores reds off top to the one
2-2
swing and a miss
15 straight brewers retired by luis
castillo
and six strikeouts today
there you go volvo back draws a walk so
that ends the streak castillo had
retired 15 straight
now the brewers get a base runner
payoff pitch and that bounced up there
so back-to-back walks
swinging a mess he struck him out
the battle of the bowl game so far goes
to luis castillo
he has made the move as the crowd stands
for la piedra
the ball two strikes lucas sims to
willie adamus
and adamus with a fly ball hit back into
left center field hitting well nate
quinn can't get it it'll bounce over the
wall
a ground rule double and that's a tough
break only one will score
vogelback is in yellow should be sent
back to third
but the rbi double from adamus and this
game is tied at two
you can read the name and number that's
a good thing here's jace peterson
lifting one into left shallow long run
winker can't get her to base hit that's
going to get yellidge home that's going
to get adamus home and it's turned into
a big inning for the brewers as they now
lead it four to two for a little more
space between himself and the bag
himself a chance to score if vogelback
can deliver and the big fella sends one
deep into right field castiano's going
back and it's gone
daniel vogel back his second home run in
as many games
as the brewers doing damage to the
cincinnati bullpen today
2-2 pitch and adamus goes the other way
castellanos can't get it that's going to
get to the wall
william thomas digging for two and it's
a two-hit afternoon for willie adamus
and the claws are out
there's peterson sending one into center
field that'll sail over tyler naquin and
that's going gonna get to the wall have
yourself a day jase peterson as he
drives in adonis
his third rbi of the day as jace
peterson gives the brewers a five-run
lead
and there's a shot into right field a
base hit that's going to get all the way
to the wall uria's on his way to third
vogel back into second
and daniel vogel back with a two-hit
afternoon he's been on base three times
overall today they're going to go ahead
and intentionally walk christian yelich
runners go again
rope to right right at castellanos
they leave them loaded great council's
team a strike away from heading home
as trevor richards finishes the game
chase peterson driving in three daniel
vogel back hitting his second home run
in his many games trevor richards
finishing things off good series for the
brew crew they take two out of three
from the reds a 7-2 winner today